In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinaxarion for July 18th, on which we commemorate, the Holy Martyr
Emilianos of Silastria in Bulgaria.
On the 18th of the month we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Emilian of Durastorum.
And Julian the Apostate seized Imperial power in the year 361.
He counted as nothing the blessings received from Saint Constantine the Great and his Christian
education.
But overturned public order by his tyranny, cursed God, and set about restoring paganism,
using every means at his disposal.
He sent those officials he had managed to win over to his cause, to the provinces, to
bring about the submission of the population.
Kapitalinas, governor of Thrace, went to Durastorum, the capital of Scythia.
On his arrival he immediately sat down in the tribunal and began to threaten with death
not only the Christians but also those who might refuse to denounce them.
Those present were so afraid that they cried out that there were no Christians in their city
and that everyone sacrificed to the Emperor's gods.
Kapitalinas reassured and full of gladness, went to attend the great banquet that had been
organized in his honor.
While they were all noisily celebrating, Emiliano, a young Christian aristocrat, unable
to remain silent at the offense being done to the true God, and Avid to carry off the
martyr's crown, let himself into the temple, armed with a hammer.
He shattered all the idols, overturned the candelabra, and the altars on which the offerings
had been placed, and poured the libations of wine onto the ground.
He then withdrew without having been observed.
When the officials told Kapitalinas what had happened, he was beside himself with rage, and
ordered that everything should be done to find those responsible.
The soldiers, finding no one and fearing to return to the tyrant, empty-handed, seized
a peasant who was returning from the fields and dragged him to the Praetorium, beating him
with rods.
Emiliano was witness to this spectacle, and refused to let an innocent man be punished in
his place.
He therefore went to hand himself over, shouting that he was the one responsible.
The soldiers, surprised, hesitated at first, but afterwards took him before Kapitalinas.
The scowling magistrate, his eyes bloodshot, ordered him to declare who he was, and what had
driven him to commit such an act.
Emiliano declared that he was both slave and free, slave of God and free of the idols,
and he added, it was love of God, and zeal for Christ, as well as the repugnance, the sight
of those inert statues aroused in me, that drove me to act, and gave me the strength to destroy
what is a cause of shame for the human race.
After there is no greater shame for us, who were created as rational beings, than to adore
beings without reason, and to bow before the work of our own hands, refusing to pay the
honor due to our only God and creator.
Enough of your rhetoric, so it was you who committed this act of sacrilege, said the
magistrate.
Emiliano replied that he regarded his action with pride as the most noble and pious act of
his life.
Kapitalinas ordered that he be stripped, stretched out on the ground, and beaten violently.
As the saint continued to mock paganism, he had him turned over that his chest might
also be struck.
Unlearning that Emiliano was the son of Sabatius, the prefect of the town, Kapitalinas declared
that his noble kinship provided no excuse for his behavior, and would not save him from punishment.
The saint himself refused to be declared innocent, or to accept the mitigating circumstances
that his interrogators tried to put forward to protect him.
But rather insisted that he be punished with all possible severity, so that he might not
be deprived of the martyr's glorious crown, seething with fury, Kapitalinas condemned him
to perish by fire, and imposed a heavy fine on his father, judging him guilty of negligence.
The soldiers immediately seized the saint, and took him out of the town to the banks of
the Danube, where a pyre had already been lit.
As soon as he had been thrown onto the pyre, the flames turned from his body towards his torturers,
burning them to cinders, while the saint continued to sing the praises of God, just as the young
men in the furnace of Babylon had done.
He made the sign of the cross, and after confiding his soul into God's hands, fell peacefully
asleep on the 18th of July, in the year 362, to be received into the assembly of the
valiant athletes of piety.
Kapitalinas' wife, who was secretly a Christian, succeeded in obtaining the body of the Holy
martyr from her husband, and confided it to devout Christians, who went to bury it in
Gizadina, three Stadia, from Durastorum.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.